welcome to this video playing relax oh
and relax all from Germany I'm playing
if or two to get to get a change here
some time playing the same stuff all the
time interesting I saw a game where are
not played f3 with some success this
still keeps the option open to place
your form so in some way I'm getting to
a default position again ok he wants to
play d5 up this lab there should be two
maybe d5 takes takes you five probably
I guess I guess f4i 9595 it's not really
great you cannot play f6 do 296 okay
probably this is my explain i'd be six
first okay f6 so this is a slight
problem this move I don't really want to
take but probably I need to hear it's
difficult difficult to not to take
this is not so bad for black figures f6
yes definite counter play against my
Center takes Bishop takes so should be
ok for black hmm not sure where where I
am made a mistake down I mean yeah in
terms of a mistake in terms of keeping
some sort of opening pool I really
should have some pool with this with the
setup but term I got nothing this is a
strange way to play it ok yeah but is
this what is this what endgame is what
what kind of endgame is this rock do I
rocked you one Bishop g4 uh-huh uh-huh
is just playing it with some technical
ideas are not interesting that's
interesting
so does this mean I have to play Bishop
e3 which this does not go down well okay
hmm it is not trade Queens why this is
now this is no interesting again for
white got Bishop b6 Bishop c5 he should
have traded Queens just trade Queens is
sex is particularly problematic because
it weakens the dark square so much k
empty one I guess
I even has problems here keeping getting
some sort of square for the Queen here
we should be a arrow p895 hmm okay 95 or
queen g3 rocky come on let's not make it
all too difficult
hmm Queen g3 10.9 f6
King King age 80 probably has to play
this
I have at least Bishop be 697 all right
this this I should have played anyway
but I don't really see a defense for him
Knight f6 here maybe cakes takes rook g8
that's very close to to being to being a
win but ok let's just play this on 97 I
could have done that the move before
yeah he really should just take
everything you can get okay takes here
and rookie seven maybe checking our v7n
to f7
yeah bishop CA drew coughs I'm Luke g8
and there should be some win if I've
probably I have everything covered yeah
f5 yeah this should be should be enough
how do i do I window the ship to the
long diagonal would be nice I come on
ff6 first year and six first
hmm I don't don't see a direct win here
unfortunately like Ali this is good yeah
Knight takes pawn takes f7 rook f8
Bishop b5 threatens threatens made on g7
and the Queen now care that's a that's a
good solution nice no he's not checks on
anything to to disturb this no that's
just Queen g7 or Bishop g7 made black
resign yeah there was nobody friends
anymore it he had a pretty good position
I think so what's this was quite quite
quite interesting night c4 at first this
looks pretty okay for white rook you one
but then you see that Bishop g4 is good
amazing so I must play I think okay the
computer wants to play Knight beehive
and ever I didn't yeah okay there is a
point I 2d6 em okay yeah I only as so
many so Bishop e3 and now he just should
should just exchange and play work the
eight something like this is it's just
ok for like I'm not sure if he is better
or just equal black has definitely some
some possibilities but night night
before and and thinks computer gives it
a sequel but given the choice I rather
have black here but this is just a
mistake yeah now I've on those dark
squares and druke the eight is coming
this is not this is really very very
good for for white
look T 1 copies on to point something
already 95 okay well this is it's both
good and here i should play Bishop b6
immediately Queen g3 was useless I can
do this oops I can do this right away I
he I can even win the club's not here to
here I can even win the Queen okay yeah
but ok this is also win it's not her not
much in doubt that that white shirt
should win f5 and GF 6 wins how exactly
ok this this and I have just check mmm
nice check check check check check check
mate yeah sometimes it would be good to
be able to calculate like a computer I
didn't say rook takes h7 at all but ok
this is also winning and here group c 7
but i think my move was good as well I
am Bishop see Sonia plus five plus five
I take this plus five is good ok maiden
the antique really must avoid this this
business here with queen of two if he
exchanges he has no problems ok thanks
for watching